[Music]
I'm starting to think as much as I like
jeopardy I'm starting to think Alex
Trebek has been hosting that show too
long I'm afraid he's starting to lose it
I'm serious
take a look barbecue for a thousand Tony
Stark builds an armored suit to help
Helen Keller escape from Guantanamo Bay
in a snowstorm that would be a prenup
shortened form back to you Greg the
blank of blank for 200 please Bill
Clinton said that women make the best
stinkhole shower gel because they can
scrape off the hardened pork like the
old-fashioned stuff you'd spread on with
a can opener baby back ribs baby back
right 1,200 place during the George W
Bush presidency The Secret Service
taught drama to fat little pro-slavery
bullfighters in preparation for a war
with the single-breasted turkeys what is
bada-bing thank you
great nationalities for 1,200 British
people drink
snake venom when suffering from
alcoholic rage in the United States we
tie up a doggy who fit across the dance
floor and spit wow that's so weird I was
just thinking about Michael Jackson's
daughter
and that disease you you are all too
young to remember polio which direction
for 200 oh my gosh Rosie O'Donnell's dog
took a crap in her mouth it helps boost
the immune system talking about
SpaghettiOs
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah he said took a crap that guy's gone
off the rails Anna pray they'll type
anything he says